we be forgiven for thinking we were  looking at Beijing or Hong Kong but this  is in fact the grayhew that is lingering  over the capital the results of a  combination of factors that's the Horan  San being blown up from Africa combined  with our own pollutants ambos being  blown in from the south and from Europe  those famous landmarks Canary Wharf The  Shard almost indistinguishable on that  grey horizon quite unprecedented  pictures of the capital there and the  warnings if you've got any sort of  respiratory or health concerns  particular with your hearts or indeed if  you suffer from asthma not to do any  exercise not even just vigorous exercise  but advised against going outside if you  have any concerns at all we'll have more  on this story throughout the morning  please keep sending us your pictures you  can send them in to our text number on  84 501 email news at SkyDome you can  also tweet me at Sky News Webster